the tragic death of gabby pitino makes
its way to the red table welcome to
entertainment tonight everyone you know
jada has covered all kinds of topics on
her show but this conversation is an
important one the search for missing
people and joining her today one of the
most famous faces who lived to tell her
terrifying tale elizabeth smart as we
learn new details about gabby's final
days
cause death by strangulation and manner
is homicide
in gabby's case in particular knowing
what it's like being on the other side
and what may have led up to her final
moments it's
heartbreaking
the body was outside for three to four
weeks
now i just need
jada's mom adrian broke down in tears at
the red table today as kidnapping
survivor elizabeth smart discussed
gabby's death and her family's plea to
prioritize all missing persons cases we
can't let her name be taken in vain this
same type of heightened awareness should
be continued for everyone every 90
seconds you know a person disappears a
person goes missing they still deserve
just every bit as much to be found so
that their stories have an ending as
well
another red table topic that police body
cam video i have a lot of anxiety cnn
senior legal analyst laura coates says
officers may have overlooked red flags
of domestic violence focusing instead on
gabby's state of mind there's a moment
when something clicks in this officer's
mind hearing she has
anxiety and something clicks and uh oh
this is what this is
right now the fbi continues to search
for gabby's boyfriend brian laundry who
is the sole person of interest in
gabby's death
this morning his dad ignored questions
about the autopsy results was your son
involved in strangling gabby
media stars including john walsh dog the
bounty hunter and nancy grace have all
taken up the case asking their followers
to help find him i firmly believe brian
laundry is very much a lie listen when
you don't know a horse
look at his track record he used her
debit cards
yes he used his dead girlfriend's debit
cards for what a drive-thru at
mcdonald's
[Music]
you